[Music]
Sleek design and state-of-the-art
Technology this is one of the most high
profile infrastructure projects in
Indonesia the trains can reach a maximum
speed of 350 kilometers per hour
this week at the close of the G20 Summit
in Bali China's president Xi Jinping
joined the Indonesian president
jokowododo to view a test of the train
we have just witnessed the operational
trial of the Jakarta Bandung high speed
Railway and I'm optimistic about the
operation of the Railway in June next
year this is one of China's many Don
Milton Road initiatives projects that
are part of the country's International
infrastructure development strategy
this is the success that benefits the
people of both countries it also brings
a positive impact to the world as a role
model for cooperation among developing
countries
the trains are also equipped with
sensors to detect earthquakes and other
threats
the railway spans more than 140
kilometers and includes 13 tunnels it
will cut travel time between Jakarta and
bundle from three hours to 40 minutes
it's the first High-Speed Rail Project
outside China that fully incorporates
Chinese technology and Equipment
some of the technology here is being
used for the first time in Indonesia we
are very proud
but the project which is mostly funded
by a loan from the China Development
Bank has been controversial the
Consortium building the railway says the
project faces cost overruns of around 2
billion dollars meaning the estimated
total cost is more than 7 billion
dollars some have criticized the amount
being spent on the project there will be
like many fundamental needs instead of
the
High technological like high-speed
Railway instead of building that kind of
infrastructures that the Indonesian
government should focusing more in the
poverty reductions China is the world's
largest creditor to developing economies
and much of that goes to infrastructure
projects but some say the new train
should be seen as an opportunity not a
liability this is also a chance for
knowledge transfer for Indonesians who
are interested in fast training
technology
Indonesians will have the chance to
assess for themselves how useful the
rail network is when it begins
operations in 2023
Jessica Washington altazira Jakarta